coblence une petite des paisibles où se
croisent le rhin et la moselle
et depuis 10 mois maintenant
l'improbable théâtre d'un procès
historique
c'est ici dans le tribunal municipal que
cinq juges doivent décider de la
culpabilité de deux hommes accusés de
crimes contre l'humanité
anwar à cela n'aurait dirigé l'unité des
enquêtes de la branche 251 des services
secrets généraux à damas et y abè gharib
lui aurait arrêté des manifestants et
les aurait emmenés à la prison de la
branche selon l'acte d'accusation qui
pèsent contre eux ils sont responsables
de 4000 cas de torture de 58 meurtre et
de deux cas d'agression sexuelle en 2011
et 2012 à quelques 4000 km la salle
d'audience en syrie serait le cas des
indes
highco don't believe est axé liane
beginning with life in a cohort tout
jeune fille louna ouafqa assiste à
chacune des audiences depuis le début du
procès en avril dernier la journaliste
aujourd'hui réfugié en allemagne est la
seule syrienne a rapporté à ses
compatriotes qu'il soit en syrie ou en
exil les horreurs qui se dévoile à
chaque semaine ici les horreurs dont il
a une connaissance intime où il dit
c'était en 2013 il n'a nouvellement
diplômée en droit documentait le
massacre alarme chimique dans la gutta
orientale quand les services de
renseignements syriens ont fait
irruption chez elle à damas ait pas de
perte immense restaurant son physique
les amis par trois fois les deux accusés
n'étaient plus les responsables à son
époque les bourreaux étaient les mêmes
si ce procès est aujourd'hui possible
c'est un peu grâce à cet homme
anouar al bounni se fond dans la foule
des réfugiés syriens installés à berlin
c'est un bien petit monde avec une route
de l'exil commune mais dont le passé
traverse des chemins parfois bien
différent
c'est comme ça qu au hasard d'un camp
d'accueil de réfugiés anwar un avocat
réputé pour la défense des droits de la
personne a croisé le chemin du colonel
déserteur panneaux des sky tree of life
reinsurance positionne au cambodge et
californie transmis au zoo momentanément
en syrie anouar al bounni avait fui lé
début du soulèvement populaire depuis la
cellule de sa prison il était depuis son
arrestation libérer quelques mois après
le début des manifestations il est
d'abord resté pour défendre nombre
croissant d'opposants arrêtés avant de
devoir prendre la fuite en 2014
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs tout est super et in my
friends à lille my friend hoarau
oui tout cas d'action internat au doute
un tapir about yens malgré la distance
entre cette menace et sa nouvelle vie
anwar al bunni n'abandonne rien de son
combat pour la justice
puis ce petit bureau de berlin l'avocat
enquêteur récolte avec d'autres
organisations des preuves et des
témoignages
il monte des dossiers judiciaires contre
ceux qui ont pensé trouver l'impunité en
allemagne wire discrimine un groupe
hyper tôt funny people because ce
spectre la justice internationale semble
jusqu'à présent paralysé par le veto
russe et chinois ou conseil de sécurité
de l'onu le procès de coblence et le
premier visant des membres du régime
syrien à se dérouler selon le principe
de compétence universelle
le dossier césar ces quelques 28 mille
photos exfiltré de syrie par le
photographe officiel des horreurs des
geôles syriennes avaient déjà parcouru
la planète
c'est ici à coblence qu'une centaine de
ces images de cadavre nu ou presque
squelettique mutilé figé dans une mort
brutale servent de preuves pour la
première fois drôle world formation
continue ou non et c'est de l'eagle par
les sinistres r10 liga le barça après
midi à l'île de chios interdit aux
livres 15,5
c'est tout le régime de bachar al assad
qui est exposée une pro 7 coblence mais
deux hommes seulement se retrouve au
banc des accusés deux hommes qui
jusqu'ici ni leurs responsabilités par
la bouche de leurs avocats seuls ces
deux hommes pourraient être reconnu
coupable à l'issue du procès n'est pas
suffisant pour luna mais c'est un tout
petit peu de justice là où on
l'attendait plus